Principal Gartner and Assistant Principal James have tried everything they know how to try. They've filed paperwork, they've talked to people above them. They've gotten the parents from their school to go and stand up at school board meetings. Nothing's worked.
Gartner校长和James副校长已经尝试了他们能想到的一切办法。他们填过表格，找过上级领导谈话。他们还组织学校的家长去学区会议上抗议。但什么用都没有。
We were told the new school would happen, this is about, six years ago.
有人告诉我们新学校会建起来，那是大概六年前的事了。
They run a public elementary school in Chicago called the Richard E. Byrd Community Academy. The school has no lunchroom, no auditorium, no gymnasium. Even for Chicago, it's pretty bad.
他们在芝加哥经营着一所名为理查德·E·伯德社区学院的公立小学。这所学校没有食堂、没有礼堂、没有体育馆。即使在芝加哥，这条件也算相当差的了。
Promises were made. Land has been cleared. A sign has been posted for years and years and years. We have gone through planning, right down to picking out tile. And then, it's not happening.
曾经有过承诺。土地也已经清理干净了。告示牌立在那儿都已经好多年好多年了。我们走完了所有规划流程，甚至连瓷砖都选好了。然后，就没有然后了。
There go our bullet hole in the window. There go our missing drinking fountain. And there go our other bullet hole in the window over there.
看我们窗上的弹孔。看我们那个缺失的饮水机。还有那边窗户上的另一个弹孔。
Caprice, a fifth grader, takes on a tour of what's wrong with the building. Things were going nowhere in the campaign to get a new school until the fifth graders in her class, room 405, got involved this fall. Among the things that got them maddest about the school was the heating system. Here's Davielle.
五年级的Caprice带我们参观了学校里不合格的地方。在她们班（405教室）的五年级学生今年秋天参与进来之前，争取新学校的运动一直毫无进展。学生们对学校最不满的事情之一就是供暖系统。这是Davielle。
At our classroom, I remember once the heat was supposed to be on but we had to put on our hats, our coats, our gloves. We put on our gloves, we can't even hardly write, because people have mittens. You know you can't write with no mittens.
在教室里，我记得有一次暖气本该开着，但我们不得不戴上帽子、穿上外套、戴上手套。戴上手套后，我们甚至几乎没法写字，因为那是连指手套。你知道，戴着连指手套是没法写字的。
They walk me to the bathrooms. There's no soap, no paper towels, no paper towel dispensers. A door is missing from the stalls.
他们带我去了卫生间。没有肥皂，没有纸巾，没有纸巾架。隔间的门也不见了。
We don't have our own privacy. There aren't any doors on the stalls. And don't nobody uses the bathroom anymore. But--
我们没有隐私。隔间上连门都没有。现在根本没人用那个卫生间了。但是——
So what does everybody do? You just hold it in?
那大家怎么办？就一直憋着吗？
Yeah, mhm. We go take it down to our lunchroom. It's a bootleg lunchroom. We've got a bootleg lunchroom, because it's a hallway with just tables in it.
是的，嗯。我们去食堂解决。那是一个“山寨”食堂。我们有个山寨食堂，因为它其实就是个放了桌子的走廊。
The bootleg lunchroom features bootleg cafeteria ladies, who look just like any cafeteria ladies anywhere, except they're serving chicken nuggets and corn and milk in the middle of the school hallway. The kids in room 405 decided that they needed a new school back in the fall when their teacher, Brian Schultz, a young idealistic teacher in his second year, decided to try something new, a program called Project Citizen, where the kids would pick some problem in the school or in their neighborhood that they wanted to solve. And then they would solve it together as a class. So one day Mr. Schultz stood at the board and had them name possible problems that they could address.
这个山寨食堂配有“山寨”食堂阿姨，她们看起来和任何地方的食堂阿姨没两样，只是她们在学校走廊中间供应鸡块、玉米和牛奶。405班的孩子们在秋天意识到他们需要一所新学校，当时他们的老师Brian Schultz，一位充满理想的年轻老师，正好处于他任教的第二年，决定尝试一些新东西，一个叫“公民计划”的项目，让孩子们挑选一个他们想要解决的学校或社区问题。然后全班一起解决它。所以有一天，Schultz先生站在黑板前，让他们列出他们可以着手解决的问题。
Some of the problems that they came up with were everything from wanting to clean up litter in the parks to teenage pregnancy to stopping Michael Jackson.
他们提出的一些问题五花八门，从清理公园里的垃圾，到未成年人怀孕，再到阻止迈克尔·杰克逊（出现在社区）。
And did you try to get them to just choose one problem?
你有试着让他们只选一个问题吗？
That was the aim, was to pick one problem. And truly I thought that they would pick something like getting mandatory recess every day, or getting a different selection of drinks at lunch.
目标确实是只选一个问题。我真心以为他们会选诸如“每天强制课间休息”或者“在午餐时增加饮料种类”之类的问题。
But when the kids started naming their problems at their own school, he says, the feeling was so many of these problems could not be solved one by one. The only way to get an auditorium or a lunchroom would probably be just to build a whole new school, the one they were supposed to get six years ago, the one whose plans are actually on display in the entryway of this building for them to see as they walk in each morning.
但他说，当孩子们开始列举学校的问题时，那种感觉是：这些问题中的许多无法逐一解决。要拥有一个礼堂或一个食堂，唯一的办法可能就是建一所全新的学校，也就是他们六年前就该得到的那所，那所学校的规划图至今还挂在教学楼入口处，每天早上他们走进去时都能看到。
So that's what they decided to go for. They've had politicians visit. They've written letters to the head of Chicago schools. There have been TV crews. There's been coverage in the newspapers.
所以这就是他们决定去争取的。他们有政客来访。他们给芝加哥学校的负责人写信。有电视台采访。报纸也进行了报道。
But Byrd sits in the middle of Cabrini-Green, one of the most famous public housing complexes in the country. And the city of Chicago is tearing down the public housing high-rises around the school. Lots of Cabrini is already gone, replaced with expensive townhomes. Assistant Principal James says that maybe the new school will come only when this process is finished.
但伯德小学位于卡布里尼-格林（Cabrini-Green）中心地带，这是全国最著名的公共住房区之一。芝加哥市正在拆除学校周围的公共住房高层建筑。卡布里尼的大部分区域已经消失，取而代之的是昂贵的联排别墅。James副校长说，也许只有当这个过程结束时，新学校才会到来。
And maybe this is what's happening. Maybe the plan is to let's just stall it, stall it, stall it until the buildings are torn down and the new townhomes are all in place and we get the population we want for the new schools, but not for our students. It'll be for the new residents, because they're going to need a school.
也许这就是正在发生的事情。也许计划就是拖延，不停地拖延，直到建筑被拆除，新的联排别墅全部就位，我们就会得到为新居民准备的新学校，但不是为我们的学生准备的。它是为新住户准备的，因为他们也会需要一所学校。
I think they're going to fix stuff up. I don't really think they're going to give us a new school.
我觉得他们只会修补一下旧的设施。我不认为他们真的会给我们一所新学校。
Yeah? How come?
是吗？为什么？
Because they're going to build condos over there. Because my mama said that when they knock down the projects, all the other people from them move over here, they're trying to make us move from over here.
因为他们要在那边盖公寓。我妈妈说，当他们拆除廉租房项目时，原本住在那儿的人就会搬到这边来，他们是想把我们赶走。
The kids are getting some small results. The school board has finally scheduled some repairs for the building, minor stuff, covering some fluorescent lights, fixing some wiring. If they just get repairs and not a whole school, a lot of kids say they're going to be really disappointed. And Principal Gartner is worried about the lesson that they're going to take away from all of this.
孩子们得到了一些微小的成果。学区终于安排了一些建筑维修，都是些小打小闹，比如遮住一些日光灯，修理一些线路。如果只是维修而不是建设一所完整的学校，很多孩子说他们会非常失望。而Gartner校长很担心他们会从中吸取什么样的教训。
If they don't see things happening, I'm afraid that they're going to say, mm hm, voice all you want, but your voice is a small voice and doesn't matter.
如果他们看不到事情有实质性的改变，我担心他们会说：嗯，随便你怎么呼吁，但你的声音很微弱，根本不重要。
And this is the problem with the big, desperate, brave attempt to change things. When you raise the stakes, you either win big or you lose big. And that's what our show is about today. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
这就是那场为了改变现状而进行的宏大、绝望且勇敢的尝试所面临的问题。当你提高筹码时，你要么大获全胜，要么输得一塌糊涂。这就是我们今天节目的主题。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是Ira Glass。
Today on our program, stories of people stuck in unfixable situations, people who try desperate measures, unusual, inventive, desperate measures. We're talking stories of American ingenuity, stories of problem solvers, stories of what this country is all about at some level.
今天在我们的节目中，讲述那些陷入无法解决困境的人们的故事，他们尝试了绝望的手段，一些非同寻常、有创造力且绝望的手段。我们讨论的是美国式创造力的故事，关于问题解决者的故事，关于这个国家本质层面的故事。
Act One, Hasta la Vista, Arnie. In that act, a patient, a doctor, a problem, and a movie star back when he still made movies.
第一幕，《再见，阿诺》。在这一幕里，有一个病人、一位医生、一个难题，以及一位还在拍电影时期的电影明星。
Act Two, We Built This City on Rock and Coal. In that act, a small town in Pennsylvania goes for the extreme makeover, decides to get a famous face of a favorite celebrity.
第二幕，《我们在摇滚和煤炭上建立的城市》。在这一幕里，宾夕法尼亚州的一个小镇为了极端的改造，决定去争取一位名人的面孔。
Act Three, The Router Not Taken. A man tries to unload a piece of junk that he bought by selling it on eBay, not by concealing its many terrible qualities, but by bragging about them, which actually, it turns out to work.
第三幕，《未被选中的路由器》。一个男人试图通过易趣（eBay）卖掉他买的一件垃圾，不是通过掩盖其众多的糟糕品质，而是通过吹嘘这些缺点，结果这居然真的奏效了。
Act Four, The Rocks at Rock Bottom. In that act, a guide to how to get over a heartbreak using only your throwing arm. Stay with us.
第四幕，《谷底的石头》。在这一幕里，一份关于如何利用你的投掷臂来走出心碎的指南。请继续收听。
Act One, Hasta la Vista, Arnie. Scott Miller was not an experienced therapist back when everything you're about to hear took place. He was a beginner, a grad student, starting off at a local psychiatric hospital when this patient came in. A guy who had been doing OK, leading a more or less normal life. When one day, the guy snapped.
第一幕，《再见，阿诺》。Scott Miller在讲述这一切发生的时候，还不是一位经验丰富的治疗师。他当时还是个初学者，一名研究生，刚进入当地一家精神病院工作，就遇到了这个病人。一个原本过得还行，过着基本正常生活的人。直到有一天，他崩溃了。
He would go on and on babbling about that he was The Terminator. And the big thing was that he had helped a bunch of other patients on this particular ward escape. They'd find them down on level two in obstetrics in there around the ward. And this had happened on more than one occasion. And they'd get a call, they would bring the people back up to the ward. And it wasn't too long before he'd be back out.
他会喋喋不休地说自己是“终结者”。最重要的一点是，他帮助了这个病房里的其他病人逃跑。他们会在二楼的产科病房周围发现那些病人。这种情况不止发生过一次。他们接到电话后，会把人带回病房。没过多久，他又会跑出去。
So he would stage breakouts?
所以他策划了越狱？
He did. He was there to rescue John Connor and had to help those people get off the ward, that they were all being kept there against their will. And in fact, he felt also that he was being poisoned by the staff, The commandant, in particular, which I took was the lead psychiatrist on the unit, given drugs that was messing up his software.
他确实这么做了。他认为自己是为了营救约翰·康纳（John Connor），必须帮助这些人离开病房，因为他们都是违背意愿被关在那里的。事实上，他也觉得工作人员在给他下毒，特别是那位“指挥官”，我理解那就是该病房的主治精神科医生，说他们在给他服用会干扰他软件的药物。
And was he quoting lines from the movies? Like would--
他会引用电影里的台词吗？比如会不会——
Oh, yes. He stayed in character, which is another unusual feature. Very often clients with this particular condition will go in and out of focus, different kinds of characters. They'll come in and out of their-- they'll remember who they are or what their role in life has been. But this guy stayed, and his delusion had fixed features.
哦，是的。他一直保持着那个角色，这是另一个不寻常的特点。通常情况下，患有这种特定病症的客户会时而清醒、时而糊涂，表现出不同的角色。他们会进出自己的——他们会记得自己是谁，或者他们在生活中扮演过什么角色。但这家伙一直坚持着，而且他的妄想有固定的特征。
So what did you do?
那么你是怎么做的？
Well, the staff was just embarrassed, but also upset with this. And they would bring him back and try to have a very rational discussion with this very psychotic man about why he shouldn't be doing this. And one of the things that often happens is they give him more of the treatment that wasn't working.
嗯，工作人员感到尴尬，但也对此感到困扰。他们会把他带回来，试图与这个精神错乱的男人进行理性的讨论，告诉他为什么他不应该这样做。通常发生的情况之一就是，他们给他增加了对他没用的治疗手段。
Like, they gave him more of the drug that didn't--
比如，他们增加了药物剂量，但这并没有——
They give him more of the drugs. And they tried even more to be rational with him and explain the reasons why he couldn't be escaping from the units, restate who he really was, what his real name was.
他们增加了药物剂量。他们甚至更加努力地与他讲道理，解释他不能逃离病房的原因，重申他到底是谁，他真正的名字是什么。
OK. So you guys try more drugs, and you try reasoning with him. Neither thing works.
好吧。所以你们增加了药物，也试图与他讲道理。但两样都没起作用。
No. And here I am a student, so I probably don't know any better. And I had been to a couple of workshops, and I was intrigued by this man whose name was Milton Erickson, who was kind of this wacky psychiatrist who lived out in the Arizona desert. He was famous for treating very difficult clients, and often in very unusual and unorthodox ways.
是的。当时我还是一名学生，所以我可能什么都不懂。我参加过几次研讨会，对一个名叫Milton Erickson的人很感兴趣，他是一位有点古怪的精神科医生，住在亚利桑那州的沙漠里。他以治疗极其困难的客户而闻名，而且经常使用非常不寻常和非正统的方法。
And the case that came to my mind, that I am sure I'd heard at this workshop, was of a man in a state hospital-- I believe it was in Michigan-- who believed he was Jesus Christ. He'd been at the hospital for decades if I'm remembering the story correctly. And nothing had helped. Milton Erickson comes in, learns of this particular case, and invites the man to his office. Or goes and visits him, I don't recall, and asks him if he is indeed Jesus Christ. The man says, yes, I am.
我脑海中浮现的一个案例，我相信我曾在研讨会上听到过，是一个州立医院的病人——我相信是在密歇根州——他相信自己是耶稣基督。如果我没记错的话，他在医院已经住了几十年了。没有任何方法起作用。Milton Erickson进来了，了解了这个特殊案例，并邀请那个人去他的办公室。或者去探望他，我不记得了，问他是否真的是耶稣基督。那个人说，是的，我是。
And Erickson, rather than fighting with him, asks him, I understand that you're a carpenter. He said, yes, that's true. And he put him to work building bookshelves at the hospital. Within a very short period of time, he's out of the hospital, working as a carpenter.
Erickson没有与他争辩，而是问他：我听说你是个木匠。那人说，是的，没错。于是他让他去医院里做书架。在很短的时间内，他出院了，并开始以木匠的身份工作。
OK, so you remember this case, and?
好吧，所以你记住了这个案例，然后呢？
So one day I come in and this young man is now in the seclusion room. So I figured it's escalated even more. This is a padded room, and they've stripped him down to his skivvies. And I asked if I could go talk with him. They said, OK. Feel free to go ahead and chat with him, if you'd like.
有一天我进来时，这个年轻人正在隔离室里。所以我认为情况变得更严重了。这是一个软包房间，他们已经剥得只剩内衣了。我问我能不能进去跟他聊聊。他们说，好的。如果你愿意，随便去跟他聊聊吧。
Right. Everything else has failed.
对了。其他一切手段都失败了。
Everything else has failed, but more, they figured there's nothing that I can do. I'm a student. I'm not going to mess things up terribly. This is a case that's going to take some time to remit.
其他一切手段都失败了，但更重要的是，他们认为我无计可施。我只是个学生。我也搞不出什么大乱子。这是一个需要很长时间才能好转的案例。
And so I went into the room. By the time I had gotten admitted to the locked room, he was sitting on the ground, cross-legged. And I walked in, and I just said, hi, my name is Scott. What can I call you? And he says, you can call me The Terminator. And so I stretched out my hand, and I say, I'm very pleased to meet you-- Terminator, or The Terminator? He says, you can just call me The Terminator.
所以我进了房间。当我进入那个上锁的房间时，他正盘腿坐在地上。我走进去，说，你好，我叫Scott。我该怎么称呼你？他说，你可以叫我“终结者”。于是我伸出手说，很高兴见到你——是“终结者”，还是“终结者”？他说，你直接叫我“终结者”就行了。
We keep talking for a while. I start to remember this case of Erickson's. And I'm thinking could I develop something similar to that, some way of joining him, some way of being with him? And I say to him at some point, out of the blue, totally by chance, are you really The Terminator or are you Arnold Schwarzenegger?
我们继续聊了一会儿。我开始想起Erickson的那个案例。我想，我能不能开发出类似的东西，某种加入他、与他产生共鸣的方式？在某个时刻，我毫无征兆地、完全凭运气地对他说：你真的是终结者，还是阿诺德·施瓦辛格？
And he stops, and he looks at me, and he says, how did you know? And he kind of smiled. And he says, you're the only one that knows this. And I say, thanks for telling me this. I said, great. I said, you know I've been watching your-- you're like an American success story. You come over here with nothing. You become an icon of weightlifting. You marry a Kennedy. My God, I said, it's incredible. We're laughing, and carrying on for another, I don't know, 10 minutes, maybe 15 minutes.
他停了下来，看着我，说，你怎么知道的？他笑了笑，又说，你是唯一知道这件事的人。我说，谢谢你告诉我。我说，太棒了。我说，你知道我一直在关注你，你简直就是一个美国成功故事。你带着一无所有来到这里。你成了举重的偶像。你娶了一位肯尼迪。天哪，我说，这太不可思议了。我们在大笑，继续聊了大概10分钟，也许15分钟。
And again, I'm sort of thinking what the next move is here. And I got an idea. I said, I have a new role for you to play. I said, you know The Terminator series, how many really of these can you do? You really need to think about developing another side, a nuanced kind of role, not just sort of stare into the camera and really just be Arnold.
然后，我再次思考下一步该怎么做。我有个主意。我说，我有一个新角色让你演。我说，你知道《终结者》系列，这电影你到底能拍多少部？你真的需要考虑开发另一个侧面，一种有细微差别的角色，而不是仅仅盯着镜头表现得像个阿诺。
And his reaction?
他的反应呢？
What's the role? And as soon as he said that, then I thought, OK, the idea seems to be working. I said, it's a very different kind of role. It's not a role that you've ever played before. It's not a strong, silent, shoot-em-up kind of type. It's not action hero. Do you think you're capable of it? And he says, oh, I'm very capable. And I said, are you sure? He says, yes. I said, well, you know I'm not-- and he says, come on! Tell me what the role is.
什么角色？他一说出口，我就想，好的，看来这个想法奏效了。我说，这是一种非常不同的角色。这不是你演过的任何角色。这不是那种强壮、沉默、枪战型的角色。这不是动作英雄。你觉得你能胜任吗？他说，哦，我很能干。我说，你确定吗？他说，是的。我说，好吧，你知道我不是——他说，来吧！快告诉我那是哪个角色。
And I said, mental patient. And in so many words he says, what do I have to do? And I said, you have to leave this room. You have to start engaging the people running around here that are pretending to be the staff. You have to talk to them about your feelings. You have to sit in groups. You have to go to arts and crafts class and paint and mold clay and do all the things that they're doing in your arts and crafts class. And he says, I can do it.
我说，精神病人。他话里的意思是，我该怎么做？我说，你必须离开这个房间。你必须开始接触那些装作是工作人员的人。你必须和他们谈谈你的感受。你必须参加小组讨论。你必须去参加艺术和工艺课，画画，捏黏土，做他们在你的艺术和工艺课上做的所有事情。他说，我可以做到。
So did he get better?
所以他变好了吗？
Yes. He was released I think within about five or six days after that. Over the course of time, he was in role so much that even he didn't seem to be able to tell that he was really Arnold Schwarzenegger.
是的。我想在大约五六天后他就出院了。随着时间的推移，他非常投入这个角色，以至于连他自己似乎都无法分辨他是否真的是阿诺德·施瓦辛格。
Right. He was just as willing to see himself as himself at some point.
对了。他在某个点上也同样愿意把自己视为他自己。
Yeah, it was equally rewarding. People got along with him well from that point forward.
是的，这同样有成就感。从那时起，人们和他相处得很好。
Oh, it's interesting to think about that in a way, his problem was that he didn't know how to relate to the world. He had some sort of breakdown, and he didn't know how to relate. And so he just chose a way to relate that it was clear how to relate. If he's Arnold Schwarzenegger, if he's The Terminator, it's clear what his role is. And all he needed for somebody to do was give him a way to think about, no no, here's who you are, and here's how to interact with the world.
哦，换个角度想很有趣，他的问题是他不知道如何与这个世界建立联系。他经历了一些崩溃，不知道如何与人交往。所以他选择了一种非常明确的交往方式。如果他是阿诺德·施瓦辛格，如果他是“终结者”，他的角色就很明确。他需要的只是有人给他一个思考方式：“不，不，这就是你，这就是你如何与世界互动的方式。”
Yeah. And let's put a twist on it. It depends on whose eyes you look through. Maybe the world needed to figure out a way to relate to him, especially the small world in which he was living. But every day, I'm meeting people. And I want to blur the boundaries a bit here between so-called delusional clients and our everyday garden-variety clients who come through the door. They also have views that I sit opposite them and think some days, how the hell could they believe that? It's so patently absurd. But my job is to somehow understand that perspective and what that leads them to. And that seems to open up a connection that leads to change.
是的。让我们换个角度看看。这取决于你透过谁的眼睛去看。也许这个世界需要找到一种与他联系的方式，特别是他所处的小世界。但我每天都在遇见各种人。我想稍微模糊一下那些所谓的妄想症客户和我们每天进门的普通客户之间的界限。他们也有一些观点，我坐在他们对面，有时会想，他们到底是怎么相信这些的？这太荒谬了。但我的工作是以某种方式理解那种观点，以及那种观点引导他们走向什么。这似乎能建立一种导致改变的连接。
How common is this as a technique to do with very extreme patients, though? This idea that you're going to enter their world in this way and enter their fantasy and just suggest a variation on the fantasy?
对于极端的病人来说，这作为一种技术有多普遍？这种你要以这种方式进入他们的世界、进入他们的幻想，并建议对幻想进行某种变化的理念？
I think the field would be divided about that. We have these notions that psychosis is a biological condition, and talking just really isn't the thing that helps them, they really need the drugs. In fact, very often people are advised, you don't actually engage people in conversations about their delusions. That might perpetuate them. So you want to make sure that you are very rational with them, set limits with them.
我想这个领域会有分歧。我们有这样一种观念：精神病是一种生物学状况，交谈并不能真正帮助他们，他们确实需要药物。事实上，人们经常被建议，不要真的去和人们讨论他们的妄想。那可能会使妄想持续下去。所以你要确保你对他们非常理性，给他们设定界限。
And with some clients, that's going to work. The question is, you try that approach, it doesn't work, you probably need to try something else. And our research actually says that clinicians frequently don't recognize when a case is failing.
对于一些客户来说，这是有效的。问题是，你尝试了那种方法但没用，你可能需要尝试别的方法。事实上，我们的研究表明，临床医生经常无法识别案例何时在失败。
Huh. So what does that mean?
呵。那意味着什么？
That means they persist in doing more of the same thing that hadn't worked before, either the same class of intervention or type of intervention. So if a little medication doesn't work, well, then we'll try a little bit more. If a little confrontation doesn't work to overcome the client's denial, then by God, we'll put them in a group where 12 people can confront them simultaneously.
这意味着他们坚持做更多之前无效的相同事情，无论是同一种干预类别还是类型。如果一点药物不起作用，好吧，那我们就多加一点。如果对抗无法克服客户的否认，那么，老天，我们就把他们放在一个12个人同时与他们对抗的小组里。
And do I understand right? You're saying that with these difficult cases, the problem isn't that people recognize, oh, this one's a stumper, and now I've got to do something different. The problem is that they actually don't recognize I'm failing in what I'm doing. I'm just doing it over and over, and it's not getting fixed.
我理解得对吗？你是说在这些困难案例中，问题不在于人们能识别出“哦，这是一个难题，现在我必须做些不同的事情”。问题在于他们实际上没有认识到“我在做的事情是失败的”。我只是在重复地做它，而它并没有被解决。
Yes, very often. So it's interesting to me that in mental health, often times when there's a problem, it's the clients who end up somehow blamed.
是的，经常如此。所以有趣的是，在心理健康领域，很多时候出现问题时，最后被责备的往往是客户。
Scott Miller is a researcher and clinician and co-director of the Institute for the Study of Therapeutic Change. Their website is www.talkingcure.com. This story is mentioned in the book, The Mummy at the Dining Room Table: Eminent Therapists reveal Their Most Unusual Cases.
Scott Miller是研究员、临床医生和治疗变革研究协会的联合主任。他们的网站是www.talkingcure.com。这个故事在《餐桌上的木乃伊：杰出治疗师揭示他们最不寻常的案例》一书中提到过。
[MUSIC - "PSYCHO THERAPY" BY THE RAMONES]
[音乐 - 雷蒙斯乐队的《心理治疗》]
Act Two, We Built This City on Rock and Coal. So here's a problem that faces the state of Michigan. Young people don't want to live there. And they're fleeing. The population of 25 to 34 year olds is half of what might be expected, down 200,000 from what it was just 10 years ago. One study shows Michigan as 47th out of the 50 states in attracting young people.
第二幕，《我们在摇滚和煤炭上建立的城市》。那么，这是密歇根州面临的一个问题。年轻人不想住在那儿。他们正在逃离。25到34岁的人口只有预期的一半，比10年前少了20万。一项研究显示，在吸引年轻人方面，密歇根州在50个州中排名第47位。
This, of course, is worrisome to the people who run the state. And their diagnosis of the problem is actually kind of interesting. They believe that young people aren't just leaving the state to get decent jobs elsewhere. They're leaving the state, they believe, because other places are just more interesting, more happening.
当然，这让负责管理这个州的人感到担忧。他们对问题的诊断其实很有意思。他们认为年轻人离开这个州不仅仅是为了去别处找体面的工作。他们认为年轻人离开是因为其他地方更有趣、更令人兴奋。
And so the Governor of Michigan, Jennifer Granholm, has decided to tackle a part of this problem the government has traditionally neglected. She wants Michigan to be more cool. And so she's launched what is called the Cool Cities Initiative, which offers grants to Saginaw and Ferndale and Romulus and other cities to quote, "create unique downtown developments where loft housing, art galleries, and technology startups can all share the same historic brick building." You get the idea.
因此，密歇根州州长Jennifer Granholm决定解决政府长期忽视的一个问题。她想让密歇根州变得更“酷”。于是她发起了所谓的“酷城市倡议”，为萨吉诺、芬代尔、罗穆卢斯和其他城市提供赠款，用他们的话说，“创造独特的市中心开发项目，让阁楼住宅、艺术画廊和科技初创公司共享同一座历史悠久的砖砌建筑。”你明白这个意思吧。
Yeah, I don't really think there's anything here for me. I would love to move out of the state.
是的，我真的不觉得这里有什么适合我的地方。我很想搬离这个州。
Nancy is one of the people who the governor is trying to reach with this program. She is 18 years old, a freshman at Lansing Community College. She says that when she and her friends talk about the Cool Cities Initiative, they just can't take it seriously.
Nancy是州长试图通过这个项目触及的人之一。她今年18岁，是兰辛社区学院的一名新生。她说当她和朋友谈论“酷城市倡议”时，她们根本无法认真对待。
I don't understand how they say a deli and a cafe, an internet cafe or whatever, is going to make this town cool. I mean, if this was coming from the youth, and they were knowing-- I wouldn't want to say the youth, because they're not necessarily youth.
我不明白他们怎么说一家熟食店、一家咖啡馆、一家网吧或者别的什么，就能让这个城镇变酷。我的意思是，如果这是来自青少年的声音，如果他们知道——我不想说“青少年”，因为他们不一定是指真正的青少年。
Is that what you all are calling yourselves these days, the youth?
你们现在都把自己称为“青少年（youth）”吗？
I always refer to myself as the youth, but--
我总是自称为“青少年”，但是——
I'm taking notes here.
我正在做笔记。
I mean, really, I kind of almost feel embarrassed for the people putting this out there.
说真的，对于那些提出这个方案的人，我甚至感到有些尴尬。
Well, one of the things that your governor says is that a big part of the initiative is getting broadband access everywhere. Do you have--
好吧，你们州长说该倡议的重要组成部分是在各地实现宽带接入。你有——
[LAUGHS] I'm sorry, what?
[笑] 对不起，你说什么？
That's just laughable to you, huh?
这让你觉得很可笑，对吧？
Yeah, that's funny to me. But go ahead.
是的，这对我来说很有趣。但你继续吧。
Why is that funny to you?
为什么这让你觉得很有趣？
Why is it funny to me? I don't see how the internet's going to make-- I mean, the cities already have broadband internet access. And everybody has a computer in their house. And everybody's-- what you need is all there. I just don't see how broadband internet access is going to draw people in.
为什么有趣？我不明白互联网怎么会——我的意思是，城市已经有宽带互联网接入了。每个人家里都有电脑。每个人都在用——你所需要的一切都在那儿。我只是看不出宽带互联网接入怎么能吸引人们。
Do you personally already have broadband internet access?
你个人已经有宽带互联网接入了吗？
Yes, at my house.
是的，在我家里。
Hm. And so that's not doing anything to keep you in the state, huh?
嗯。所以这并没有起到什么作用让你留在州里，对吧？
No. Not in the least. I mean, where can't you get it?
没有。一点也没有。我的意思是，哪儿没有宽带呢？
Let me just read to you a couple of sentences from your governor's state of the state address. "So the fourth way we will grow the economy is by spurring strong regional economies anchored by cool cities. We can have local commissions on cool. Government can't create cool. But we can and will target existing resources to support local efforts, to have vibrant cities." Do you find it disturbing to hear the governor say the word "cool" so many times?
让我给你读几句你们州长在州情咨文中的话。“所以我们促进经济增长的第四种方式是促进以酷城市为锚点的区域经济。我们可以设立地方酷委员会。政府无法创造酷。但我们能够并将针对现有资源支持地方努力，以拥有充满活力的城市。”你听到州长这么多次使用“酷”这个词，会感到不安吗？
I'm so glad you said that. Yeah. Everything is dotted with cool and hip everywhere. They just seem so out of touch, almost. They're speaking about the youth like this different species of-- maybe we can be cool like them. It's like if you came home and your mom decided to redecorate your room so it was cool and hip. And she'll do what she thinks you'll like, but your mom doesn't have the same idea of what's cool and hip.
很高兴你这么说。是的。到处都点缀着“酷”和“时髦”。他们看起来太脱节了。他们谈论年轻人的方式就像谈论一个不同的物种——也许我们可以像他们一样酷。这就像你回到家，你妈妈决定重新装饰你的房间，这样它就会显得又酷又时髦。她会做她认为你会喜欢的，但你妈妈和你对什么叫酷和时髦的理解完全不同。
Which brings us to this story, about a town in Eastern Pennsylvania that was in such desperate straits that it took some very unusual measures. It didn't just try to bring in broadband internet access. It did what ex-cons do, what aspiring starlets do, what immigrants do, what people in the witness protection program do. It changed its name.
这就引出了这个故事，关于宾夕法尼亚州东部的一个城镇，它处于如此绝望的境地，以至于采取了一些非常不寻常的措施。它不仅试图引入宽带互联网接入。它做了前科犯所做的事情，像有抱负的明星、移民、证人保护计划中的人所做的事情。它改了名字。
It changed its name to the name of a person, a person who actually never set foot in the town. A man named Jim Thorpe. One of our producers, Sarah Koenig, visited there recently.
它改成了一个人的名字，一个从未踏足过这个城镇的人。一个名叫Jim Thorpe的男人。我们的制作人之一Sarah Koenig最近去过那里。
The name change happened 50 years ago. But still, if you ask two people here, people who live just down the street from each other, what's the name of their hometown, you can end up in a discussion like this.
改名发生在50年前。但即便如此，如果你问这里住在这条街对面的两个人，他们的家乡叫什么名字，你可能会陷入这样的讨论。
You say to somebody, it's like, I go to meet somebody. I go up the Hazelton River. Where are you from? I'm from Chunk. Then they know you're no phony.
你对某人说，比如，我去见某人。我沿着Hazelton河上去。你是哪儿人？我是Chunk人。那样他们就知道你不是冒牌货了。
And you? And you Craig?
那你呢？Craig呢？
Oh, I'm from Jim Thorpe. There's no doubt about it. Born 1959--
哦，我来自Jim Thorpe。毫无疑问。1959年出生——
You work at the Jim Thorpe National Bank, for Christ's sake.
你看，你都在Jim Thorpe国家银行工作，看在上帝的份上。
But we were one of those places that went from Mauch Chunk National Bank to Jim Thorpe. We changed our name in honor and respect.
但我们是那些从Mauch Chunk国家银行变成Jim Thorpe国家银行的地方之一。我们为了尊重和纪念而改名。
Chunkers are Chunkers and Thorpers are Thorpers.
Chunk人就是Chunk人，Thorpe人就是Thorpe人。
This place had its heyday in the late 1800s, back when it was two towns, one name each, Mauch Chunk and East Mauch Chunk. It got rich off coal, when people started hauling anthracite to market along the canal. They built a railroad, one of the first in America. And by the turn of the 20th century, it claimed to have more millionaires per capita than anywhere else in the country. Thousands of tourists came here, and checked into one of the nation's biggest hotels, where five presidents stayed.
这个地方在19世纪末处于全盛时期，当时它是两个城镇，各有各的名字，Mauch Chunk和东Mauch Chunk。它靠煤炭发了财，当时人们开始沿着运河把无烟煤运往市场。他们修建了一条铁路，是美国最早的铁路之一。到20世纪之交，它声称拥有的人均百万富翁数量比全国任何地方都多。成千上万的游客来到这里，住进全国最大的酒店之一，五位总统曾住过那里。
You could probably get a good view over here.
你可能在那边能看到很好的景色。
Bob Knappenberger, who's lived here all his life, took me on a tour. We drove to the top of a big hill and looked down on the houses tucked neatly into the valley.
Bob Knappenberger一辈子都住在这里，他带我参观了一圈。我们开车到了一座大山的山顶，俯瞰着整齐地坐落在山谷中的房屋。
Now that road coming down there off to your left, see, that's the Asa Packer Mansion.
现在那条从左边下来的路，看到了吗，那是Asa Packer大厦。
And so you were saying they called this the Switzerland--
所以你刚才说他们称这里为瑞士——
Switzerland of America. If you look down here, you could see why they call it. And there was a big restaurant here, right here. You'd come up here and have dinner at night and sit out on the veranda. The bear would be walking right there. You'd throw some food out to him.
美国的瑞士。如果你往下看，就能看出为什么他们这么称呼它。这儿曾经有一家大餐馆，就在这儿。你会来到这里，晚上吃晚饭，坐在阳台上。熊就在那儿走来走去。你会扔些食物给它。
Really?
真的吗？
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
He tells me Tommy and Jimmy Dorsey got their start playing in the dance hall attached to the dining room. It's dilapidated now, the wooden ballroom kind of sagging. After the Depression and World War II, the coal business started dying here, and a lot of people lost their jobs. And soon the biggest employer, the railroads, started closing too, until they didn't even stop in Mauch Chunk anymore. People say by the early '50s, at 6:00 AM, you'd see all these cars driving away, taking people to work out of town. They'd go to Bethlehem to the steel mill, or to factories in Allentown.
他告诉我Tommy和Jimmy Dorsey兄弟就是在附属饭厅的舞厅开始他们的表演的。现在已经破败了，木制舞厅有点下垂。大萧条和二战后，煤炭生意开始在这里衰落，许多人失业了。不久，最大的雇主——铁路公司也开始关闭，直到他们甚至不再在Mauch Chunk停车。人们说，到50年代初，早上6点，你会看到所有这些车都开走了，把人们载到城外去工作。他们去伯利恒的钢铁厂，或者去阿伦敦的工厂。
And this is where a man named Joe Boyle comes in. Joe and his father owned the newspaper in town, the Mauch Chunk Times News. Boyle died in 1992, but he still holds a kind of mythic status here as a tireless town booster who churned out scheme after scheme in the name of progress.
这就是Joe Boyle这个人出现的地方。Joe和他的父亲拥有镇上的报纸——《Mauch Chunk时报》。Boyle于1992年去世，但他在这里仍然保持着一种神话般的地位，作为一个不知疲倦的城镇推动者，他以进步的名义搞出了一项又一项计划。
He was ahead of his time. He was just so onto the future, one of those very rare people.
他走在时代的前列。他就是如此面向未来，是那种非常罕见的人。
Joe could sell us on anything, because we loved that man, admired that man, and he would never lead us astray.
Joe能让我们相信任何事情，因为我们爱那个男人，钦佩那个男人，他永远不会把我们引入歧途。
Most people liked Joe, but he did have some pretty funny ideas.
大多数人喜欢Joe，但他确实有一些非常有趣的想法。
In 1950, Joe Boyle literally dreamed up a way to save the two towns, to bring in new industry. He woke up at 3:00 AM, he told a reporter, with a crazy idea. He would ask every man, woman, and child to contribute a nickel a week to a common fund for a period of seven years. That's how long he thought it would take to collect enough money for an industrial building. And then they'd get businessmen to fill it.
1950年，Joe Boyle真的想出了一个拯救这两个城镇的方法，以引入新的工业。他告诉一位记者，他在凌晨3点醒来，有一个疯狂的想法。他将要求每个男人、女人和孩子每周为一个共同基金捐出一镍币，持续七年。他认为这需要足够的时间来为一座工业大楼筹集足够的资金。然后他们会请商人来入驻。
So people went around with buckets and collected nickels. They even put a strip of tape along the main road and asked drivers coming into town to stick a nickel on the tape. The nickel a week fund started making money, and a story about it ran on the national AP wire, and then got picked up by TV. It's at this point that the towns happened to cross paths with Jim Thorpe, or at least the body of Jim Thorpe. He had died in 1953.
所以人们提着桶到处收集镍币。他们甚至在主干道上贴了一条带子，要求开车进城的司机把镍币贴在带子上。每周一镍币的基金开始赚钱，关于它的故事登上了全国美联社电报，后来被电视报道。就在这时，这两个城镇碰巧与Jim Thorpe的人生轨迹交叉了，至少是Jim Thorpe的遗体。他于1953年去世。
Thorpe, like the Mauch Chunk towns, had been at the height of his glory almost 50 years earlier. He was a Sac and Fox Indian from Oklahoma who became a legendary sports figure. They made a movie about him, Jim Thorpe, All-American. Burt Lancaster stars.
Thorpe和Mauch Chunk镇一样，在近50年前处于他荣耀的巅峰。他是一位来自俄克拉荷马州的索克与福克斯印第安人，成为了一位传奇的体育人物。他们拍了一部关于他的电影，《吉姆·索普——全能运动员》。Burt Lancaster主演。
Pretty good, Jim. Very good for a first jump. Let's try it again. Watching Thorpe in succeeding weeks was like watching a magnificent young stallion, untamed and unbroken.
跳得很好，吉姆。第一次跳跃就表现得很好。我们再试一次。在接下来的几周里观看Thorpe就像观看一匹雄伟的种马，未被驯服，未被折服。
The film tells how Thorpe won the pentathlon and decathlon in the 1912 Olympics, a feat that's never been repeated.
电影讲述了Thorpe如何赢得1912年奥运会的五项全能和十项全能，这是一个从未被重复的壮举。
And when it was over, the King of Sweden asked to meet Jim Thorpe, to pay personal tribute.
当比赛结束时，瑞典国王要求见Jim Thorpe，向他致敬。
Sir, you are the greatest athlete in the world.
先生，你是世界上最伟大的运动员。
Thank you, Your Majesty.
谢谢，陛下。
Thorpe was also a football Hall of Famer, a professional baseball player, and a champion in lacrosse, swimming, and skating. He also played hockey, handball, and tennis, boxed, fished, sailed, shot golf, and bowled, and was a great dancer. Basically, there wasn't any physical thing he couldn't do.
Thorpe也是橄榄球名人堂成员、职业棒球运动员，还是曲棍球、游泳和滑冰的冠军。他还打过冰球、手球和网球，打过拳击、钓鱼、航海、高尔夫和保龄球，还是一位出色的舞者。基本上，没有他做不到的身体活动。
But a lot of his life was tragic. His Olympic medals were stripped from him in 1913, because he had played some baseball for a little money a few years earlier, and he never really got over it. He lost a child to polio and drank a lot, fouling up his first two marriages. And he couldn't seem to hang on to money. He ended up working sad kinds of jobs, emceeing dance contests, or playing bit parts in movies, or working as a laborer with a pick and shovel. He died in California in his house trailer of a heart attack. He was 65.
但他的一生非常悲惨。他的奥运奖牌在1913年被剥夺，因为他几年前为了钱打过棒球，他从未真正从中恢复过来。他因脊髓灰质炎失去了一个孩子，酗酒成性，搞砸了他的前两次婚姻。他似乎无法留住钱。他最终做着悲惨的工作，主持舞蹈比赛，在电影里演小角色，或者做一名拿着镐和铲子的苦力。他在加州的房车里因心脏病去世。他65岁。
Patricia, his widow, tried to get his home state of Oklahoma to build a memorial to him. But the governor eventually vetoed the idea. So she came East looking for help and, by most accounts, money. She was in Philadelphia when she saw a TV story about a plucky little town nearby that had amassed a small fortune in nickels. Bob Knappenberger was working at the American Hotel at the time.
他的遗孀Patricia试图让他所属的俄克拉荷马州为他建造一座纪念碑。但州长最终否决了这个想法。所以她来到东部寻求帮助，根据大多数人的说法，她是在寻求金钱。当她在费城看到一个关于附近一个勇敢的小镇筹集了一小笔镍币财富的电视报道时，她就在那儿。Bob Knappenberger当时在美国酒店工作。
Now, this lady had come in. I'll never forget it. She had come in, and she had a poodle dog in each hand. And she said to me, young man-- that's exactly what she said. I was a young man then, I'm now 78. She said, do you have a chamber of commerce? I says, no we don't. But the secretary of our borough is right across the street. The Acme store used to be right across the street which is now Anne's Early Attic. Everything used to congregate around the American Hotel there. Within a few hours, talk was around that it was Mrs. Thorpe here.
现在，这位女士进来了。我永远不会忘记它。她走了进来，两只手各牵着一只贵宾犬。她对我说，年轻人——这就是她说的。我那时还是个年轻人，现在我78岁了。她说，你们有商会吗？我说，没有。但我们的自治市镇秘书就在街对面。Acme商店以前就在街对面，现在是Anne's Early Attic。以前一切都聚集在酒店周围。几个小时之内，城里都在谈论Thorpe夫人来了。
As soon as she got to town, Patricia Thorpe hooked up with newspaperman Joe Boyle. And this was her pitch. The town would pay her for the right to bury her famous husband, build him a memorial, and change its name to Jim Thorpe, PA. In exchange, she said, the town would cash in on his name and Mrs. Thorpe's connections. The head of the NFL was a friend of her husband's.
她一到镇上，Patricia Thorpe就联系了报人Joe Boyle。这就是她的推销辞：镇上将为安葬她著名的丈夫的权利支付费用，为他建造一座纪念碑，并将其名字更改为Jim Thorpe, PA。作为交换，她说，镇上将利用他的名字和Thorpe夫人的关系。NFL的总裁是她丈夫的朋友。
They would set up a national charity foundation in Thorpe's name that she said would raise money for a $10 million heart and cancer research hospital that would be built in town. There was talk of establishing the NFL Hall of Fame there, maybe a sporting goods manufacturer, maybe even a motel called Jim Thorpe's Tepees. Tourists were sure to come, just like in the old days.
他们将在Thorpe的名义下建立一个全国性的慈善基金会，她说，这将为镇上建造一座耗资1000万美元的心脏和癌症研究医院筹集资金。有传言说要在那里建立NFL名人堂，也许是一个体育用品制造商，甚至可能是一个叫Jim Thorpe帐篷的汽车旅馆。游客一定会来的，就像过去一样。
Boyle initially thought the idea was preposterous, he said. But it grew on him, as a way for the two towns to unite under this new name. He started running stories about it in the newspaper almost every day. He even printed an architectural sketch of the hospital. The notion started to catch on that the very existence of the towns was at stake. On May 17, 1954, a day before the town voted on the name change, Boyle wrote in his column, "the voters will decide whether or not the twin communities will merge and be known as Jim Thorpe, Pennsylvania, or drop into complete oblivion." Again, Bob Knappenberger.
Boyle起初认为这个想法荒谬至极，他说。但它对他产生的影响越来越大，这成了这两个城镇以这个新名字团结起来的一种方式。他开始在报纸上几乎每天都刊登相关报道。他甚至印制了一张医院的建筑草图。在这个城镇的存亡岌岌可危的观念开始流行起来。1954年5月17日，在镇上投票表决改名的前一天，Boyle在他的专栏中写道：“选民将决定这两个社区是否合并并被称为Jim Thorpe，宾夕法尼亚州，还是陷入彻底的遗忘。”再次请出Bob Knappenberger。
And were there people who didn't want them joined?
有人不想让他们合并吗？
The older ones. The older ones were, "oh!" But it passed 10 to 1. And I'll never forget the night of the general election. I sent a telegram to, well, I don't know how many major newspapers. That night, I said on the teletype, I said, Mauch Chunk, Pennsylvania is now Jim Thorpe. I'll never forget it. Yeah. I thought it was great. Believe me, I did. I thought it was great.
年长的人。年长的人说，“哦！”但它以10比1的投票结果通过了。我永远不会忘记大选之夜。我给很多大报社发了电报。那天晚上，我在电传打字机上说，Mauch Chunk，宾夕法尼亚州现在改名为Jim Thorpe。我永远不会忘记它。是的。我觉得这很棒。相信我，确实。我觉得这很棒。
So the body of Jim Thorpe was finally buried. Using $10,000, or 200,000 nickels, they built a red marble mausoleum the size of a large bathtub. There are carvings of Thorpe throwing a discus and jumping a hurdle, and the words, "sir, you are the greatest athlete in the world." It sits just off the roadside on the outskirts of town. Eydie Lukasavige, a member of the town council, was about 20 at the time. And she remembers how hopeful everybody was.
所以Jim Thorpe的遗体终于下葬了。他们用1万美元，也就是20万个镍币，建造了一个像大浴缸那么大的红色大理石陵墓。上面雕刻着Thorpe扔铁饼和跨栏的图案，以及“先生，你是世界上最伟大的运动员”这句话。它就坐落在镇郊的路边。镇议会成员Eydie Lukasavige当时大约20岁。她记得大家当时是多么充满希望。
Are you kidding? We thought it was the greatest thing since the coming of-- you know what. It was wonderful. It was going to do something for the community. It was going to put us on the map. And it just never happened. And people just stopped talking about it. But when you bring all this up, they'll say, yeah, remember? We were promised this, and we were promised that. And what did we get? We got nothing.
你在开玩笑吗？我们以为这是自……你知道那件事以来最伟大的事情。太棒了。它将为社区做点什么。它将让我们名扬四海。但它从来没发生过。人们就不再谈论它了。但当你提起这一切时，他们会说，是啊，还记得吗？我们被承诺了这个，被承诺了那个。我们得到了什么？我们什么也没得到。
Nothing. Not one new building, not one new business. And the Football Hall of Fame? It went to Canton, Ohio, where it has gotten more than 7 million tourists since it opened in 1963. Some people blame Mrs. Thorpe. Other people blame Bert Bell, or the lack of him. He was the head of the NFL, and the Chairman of the Jim Thorpe Foundation. And the day he was supposed to go on national television to kick off the fundraising campaign, he was at a Philadelphia Eagles game, and he collapsed and died right on the field. And that was it. Nobody took up the cause after that. And people started to get mad. Ray Hills remembers bringing his boy scout troop to town around that time.
什么都没有。没有一栋新楼，没有一家新企业。至于橄榄球名人堂？它去了俄亥俄州的坎顿，自1963年开放以来，那里接待了超过700万游客。有些人怪Thorpe夫人。其他人怪Bert Bell，或者说怪他不在了。他是NFL的总裁，也是Jim Thorpe基金会的主席。就在他本该上全国电视启动筹款活动的那一天，他在一场费城老鹰队的比赛中，倒在球场上当场死亡。就是这样。之后没人再继续这项事业了。人们开始变得愤怒。Ray Hills记得大约在那时带他的童子军去镇上。
During the course of the weekend, we went down to look at Jim Thorpe's memorial. And I talked to scout troops, because I thought it would be pretty good for the scouts to see. And it was like demolished and had graffiti all over the monument.
那个周末，我们去看了Jim Thorpe的纪念碑。我告诉童子军们，因为我觉得让童子军们看看会挺好的。结果它就像被拆毁了一样，纪念碑上全是涂鸦。
The marble, you mean, part?
你是说大理石的那部分？
Somebody had come down there with sledgehammers and gave it a work over. Because all they said they ever had was a dead Indian. They never got anything from Jim Thorpe's wife, when she said she was going to dedicate a hospital or a library, something of that sort in town. And they never got it, but a dead Indian.
有人带着大锤过来把它砸了一顿。因为他们说他们得到的只有一个死去的印第安人。Jim Thorpe的妻子承诺要捐赠一座医院或图书馆，或者类似的东西，他们从来没得到任何东西，只有一个死印第安人。
A faction of older residents were so embittered, they started a movement to change the name back to Mauch Chunk. In 1964, 10 years after the first switch, the town put it to the voters again. They decided to remain Jim Thorpe, but the tally was much, much closer. Things eventually settled down, but the economy kept sliding. By the 1970s, the beautiful downtown buildings began to fall apart, and shop windows were mostly empty. Then Thorpe's children hired a lawyer in an effort to disinter his body and bury him in the family plot near Shawnee in Oklahoma, but nothing ever came of that either.
一部分老居民对此感到如此愤恨，他们发起了一场改回Mauch Chunk名字的运动。1964年，在第一次改名10年后，镇上再次让选民投票。他们决定保留Jim Thorpe，但票数接近得多得多。事情最终平息了下来，但经济持续下滑。到了20世纪70年代，美丽的市中心建筑开始倒塌，店面大多空空如也。后来Thorpe的孩子们雇了一名律师，试图挖出他的遗体并把他埋在俄克拉荷马州肖尼附近的家族墓地，但这也没能实现。
In a scheme designed--
在一个旨在——
Today, the video for sale in the Mauch Chunk museum refers to the town's name change in a tone that, for a local historical video, seems oddly hostile.
今天，Mauch Chunk博物馆出售的视频以一种对当地历史视频来说显得格格不入且带有敌意的语气提到了城镇的名字变更。
In return, Mrs. Thorpe promised the balance of her husband's estate to build a $10 million, 400-bed hospital. While this bizarre exchange received nationwide headlines, it did little to change the town. Only controversy resulted from the name change, controversy which haunts the town to this day.
作为回报，Thorpe夫人承诺用她丈夫遗产的余额来建造一座价值1000万美元、拥有400张床位的医院。虽然这一奇怪的交易登上了全国头条，但它对改变城镇几乎没有起到任何作用。改名只带来了争议，这种争议至今仍困扰着这个城镇。
I guess maybe we were living in a dream world. I guess maybe our families were living in a dream world.
我想也许我们生活在一个梦幻世界里。我想也许我们的家人生活在一个梦幻世界里。
Eydie Lukasavige, like a lot of people you meet here, thinks the town did right by Jim Thorpe. But she also thinks the whole scheme was half-baked to begin with.
Eydie Lukasavige像你在里遇见的许多人一样，认为这个镇对Jim Thorpe做得很公道。但她也认为整个计划从一开始就不成熟。
Can you imagine that kind of campaign happening now, and people going--
你能想象这种运动现在发生，人们去——
Never. Never. It could never happen now.
绝不可能。绝不可能。它现在绝不可能发生。
Why?
为什么？
It could never happen now because I think we're all a little smarter. I don't think we're as gullible as people may have been back then. I think we would do a lot more checking into it to make sure that this is for real. It's like my getting a letter today telling me that I won $670,000. You know, maybe back in the '50s I might have been gullible enough to believe it, but I wouldn't believe it today. No, I don't think you could sell a bill of goods like that today.
它现在绝不可能发生，因为我想我们都更聪明一点了。我不认为我们像当时的人们那样容易受骗。我想我们会做更多的调查，以确保这是真的。这就像我今天收到一封信，说我赢了67万美元。你知道，也许在50年代我可能天真到会相信它，但我今天绝不会相信。不，我不认为你今天能卖出这种假货。
But my children were all very happy with the name of Jim Thorpe. When I'd say to them, oh, I don't know why we give up the name of Mauch Chunk, they'd say, what's the matter with you? Jim Thorpe's a great name. Well, sure, it's a great name. But I couldn't see Lansford changing their name, or Nesquehoning or Coaldale. None of those coal mining towns would ever change the names of their towns for nothing. For nothing. You know, you've got to be proud of what you have and work with what you have.
但我的孩子们都对Jim Thorpe这个名字很满意。当我对他们说，哦，我不知道为什么要放弃Mauch Chunk这个名字时，他们会说，你怎么了？Jim Thorpe是个伟大的名字。嗯，当然，这是个伟大的名字。但我无法想象Lansford会改名，或者Nesquehoning或Coaldale。那些煤矿城镇绝不会为了什么都没有而改名。什么都没有。你知道，你必须为你拥有的东西感到自豪，并利用你拥有的东西努力工作。
In the last few years, the town has been doing much better. Jim Thorpe now survives on tourists who come not to see the mausoleum, but to go hiking and whitewater rafting and look at the restored downtown and go to all the nice shops. And maybe all of that's possible exactly because Joe Boyle's plan failed and no industry ever came here to spoil the river and surrounding hills. Because 50 years after the name change, Jim Thorpe still looks exactly like Mauch Chunk.
在过去几年里，这个小镇的状况好多了。Jim Thorpe现在靠游客生存，他们来这里不是为了看陵墓，而是为了徒步旅行、白水漂流、看修复后的市中心和去那些漂亮的商店。也许这一切之所以可能，正是因为Joe Boyle的计划失败了，没有工业来到这里破坏河流和周围的山丘。因为在改名50年后，Jim Thorpe看起来仍然和Mauch Chunk一模一样。
Sarah Koenig is one of the producers of our show.
Sarah Koenig是我们节目的制作人之一。
[MUSIC - "ISTANBUL (NOT CONSTANTINOPLE)" BY THEY MIGHT BE GIANTS]
[音乐 - 巨人乐队的《伊斯坦布尔（不是君士坦丁堡）》]
Coming up, an engineer's brain and a broken heart. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，一个工程师的头脑和一颗破碎的心。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台的节目将继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Desperate Measures, stories of people in impossible situations trying to invent their way out of them. In this, the second half of our show, we have two stories. And I'm not sure if both of these guys are full-time engineers, but they're certainly engineer types, guys who take stuff apart and think it through.
这里是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。当然，每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目，“绝望的手段”，讲述人们处于不可能的境地中试图发明方法走出来。在节目的下半部分，我们有两个故事。我不确定这两个家伙是否是全职工程师，但他们绝对是工程师类型的人，那种拆解东西并深入思考的人。
We have now arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, The Router Not Taken.
我们现在进入节目的第三幕。第三幕，《未被选中的路由器》。
My name is Dave and I put a listing on eBay called Ryobi Router Table, Worthless Junk, No Reserve.
我叫Dave，我在易趣上发了一个名为“Ryobi路由器台，一文不值的垃圾，不设底价”的清单。
Now this story of American ingenuity. Dave and his wife were expecting a baby. And he decided to build a crib for the baby. So he went to Home Depot, and he bought this machine that would help him do the job. The cheapest model that he could find, since really he had no idea when he would ever want to use the thing again.
现在这个美国式创造力的故事。Dave和他的妻子在等一个孩子。他决定为孩子做一个婴儿床。所以他去了家得宝（Home Depot），买了一台能帮他完成工作的机器。这是他能找到的最便宜的型号，因为他真不知道什么时候还会用到这玩意儿。
This item is a router table. And it essentially is a support for a router. And what this item does is it will take a piece of wood and put a decorative edge on the piece of the wood.
这是一个路由器台。它本质上是一个路由器的支撑架。这个东西的作用是把一块木头放上去，在木头边缘做装饰。
And basically, it just guides you as you're cutting the piece of wood, right?
基本上，它只是引导你切割木头，对吧？
Right. The table guides you or the wood, depending on what you're trying to do. And the router itself, which mounts to the bottom of the table, actually does the work. So the table's used more for precision-type work. If you're making pieces that mate together, then you'd want to use the table to make sure that you got everything perfect.
对。台子引导你或者引导木头，取决于你想做什么。而安装在台子底部的路由器本身才是干活的。所以台子更多是用于精密工作。如果你要做拼合在一起的零件，那你就想用台子来确保一切都很完美。
And so that's what it's supposed to do. What did this one do?
这就是它应该做的。那这一个做了什么？
This one didn't do pretty much anything right. Basically the table was falling apart, and it caused me a lot of quality problems, I guess, with my work. And also, it was pretty much a safety nightmare as well. I've got this router bit spinning at 15,000 RPM, and my finger is three inches away from it. And all of a sudden, it decides to move.
这一个几乎什么都没做对。基本上台子要散架了，它给我造成了很多质量问题，我想，我的工作。而且，它本质上也是一个安全噩梦。我的路由器钻头以15000转/分的速度旋转，我的手指离它只有三英寸远。突然之间，它决定移动了。
Because the legs were falling off, I had to wedge it against the wall and jam my knee underneath it and hold it with one hand against the wall, and my knee and the other hand, I was trying to guide the wood. It wasn't real safe, but I do still have all 10 of my fingers.
因为腿要掉下来了，我不得不把它楔在墙上，把膝盖塞在下面，用一只手靠着墙固定它，用膝盖和另一只手试图引导木头。这并不真正安全，但我确实还有全部10个手指。
So you came up with a totally ingenious solution for what to do this. You basically decided to sell it on eBay. Can I ask you to read from your listing that was posted on eBay?
所以你对这个情况想出了一个绝妙的解决方案。你基本上决定在易趣上卖掉它。我可以请你读一下你在易趣上发布的清单吗？
Sure. "This Ryobi router table was the worst thing I've ever spent money on. Period. I've wasted money on a lot of things in my life, women, cars, lots of other things I didn't need. You name it. But I never felt like I totally 100% wasted my money on something until I bought this table. This is the most worthless piece of crap I've ever had the displeasure of working with in my life."
当然。“这个Ryobi路由器台是我花过钱买的最糟糕的东西。句号。我这辈子在很多事情上浪费过钱，女人，汽车，还有其他我不需要的很多东西。随便什么。但我从来没觉得我像买这个台子一样，100%浪费了我的钱。这是我有生以来被迫使用的最无价值的垃圾。”
What I love about this is just how completely categorical it is.
我喜欢这一点，因为它太彻底了。
Well, it's kind of an anti-description. Most of your descriptions try to tell you how good something is on eBay. And then this one I just decided to go the totally opposite way and explain how bad it was.
嗯，这是一种反描述。易趣上大多数描述都试图告诉你东西有多好。而这一次，我决定走完全相反的路线，解释它有多糟糕。
I'm going to ask you to read some of the next paragraph.
我要请你读一下下一段的一部分。
OK. "It comes complete with most of the crappy accessories it came with. An example is the plastic pusher mitre thingy that's so sloppy that I don't understand why they even bothered making it adjustable. It's really nice when you're trying to route something at an angle and it slips in the middle of the cut and jerks the work piece right out of your hands and flings it across the room. Or the super anti-precision fence that's almost impossible to adjust and keep in place. Or the slippery painted surface that wears off, exposing the rough surface that mars the work piece as you slide it over. It does come with a power switch that always worked. I'll give it that. It has a really nice power switch. Some of the other small items got destroyed in a fit of rage one day after fighting it for a couple of hours."
好的。“它配齐了随附的大部分蹩脚配件。一个例子是那个塑料推杆斜接器，它松垮得让我不明白他们为什么还要费心把它做成可调的。当你试图以一定角度路由东西时，它会在切割过程中打滑，把工件从你手中拽走，扔到房间另一头，这感觉真的很棒。还有那个超级反精密的栅栏，几乎不可能调整并保持在原位。还有那个滑溜溜的漆面，漆磨掉后露出粗糙的表面，当你滑过它时会损坏工件。它确实带有一个一直有效的电源开关。我承认这一点。它有一个非常好的电源开关。在为它斗争了几个小时后，有一天我发火把一些其他小零件给毁了。”
Then you go on and you say that the best part of it is that it is a three-legged router table.
然后你接着说，最好的一部分是它是一个三条腿的路由器台。
Right, right. Well, it became a three-legged after I was trying to route something one day and I noticed that the table was moving. Then well after a few more pieces, I'm in the middle of a cut and the leg just fell off. So I had to stop to keep from losing any fingers and I tried to beat the plastic inserts back in. When I took the picture, I had the table supported by a beer bottle to keep it from falling over.
对，对。嗯，在我有一天试图路由东西注意到台子在移动后，它就成了三条腿。然后，在又做了几个零件后，我正在切割过程中，腿就掉下来了。所以我不得不停下来以防失去任何手指，我试图把塑料嵌件敲回去。拍照时，我用一瓶啤酒支撑着台子，以免它倒下来。
All right. Keep going in the reading.
好了。继续读。
"This table comes with no warranty from me. I never bothered to try to take it back, even though it was under warranty. I was so ticked off that I knew I'd create a scene when I threw it through the front window of Home Depot."
“这个台子我没有任何保修。我从来没费心去退货，尽管它还在保修期内。我太生气了，我知道如果我把它扔进家得宝的前窗，我会闹出乱子的。”
And then you go on and you explain how to ship it and blah-blah-blah-blah-blah. And so it seems like it was the listing when you first sent it out. And then people started writing you. What kinds of emails were you getting?
然后你接着解释怎么运输它等等等等。所以它看起来像是你第一次发布时的清单。然后人们开始给你写邮件。你收到什么样的邮件？
I was getting all sorts of emails. I think to date I've got close to 1,000 emails on this. But the first ones that came in, I got a lot of requests to shoot it or set it on fire, or make a video of some sort of destruction of the table.
我收到了各种各样的邮件。我想迄今为止关于这个我已经收到了近1000封邮件。但最初进来的那些，我收到了很多让我射击它或放火烧它，或者制作某种销毁台子的视频的请求。
Right. And why don't you read the addendum that you added in mid-March based on this emails.
对。你为什么不读一下你在3月中旬根据这些邮件添加的附录。
OK. "I received some emails. And yes, I am willing to set it on fire, shoot it full of holes, et cetera, and mail a picture/video to you. If the bid gets high enough to cover my costs, I'll be willing to shoot it full of holes with your choice of the following-- 12-gauge slugs, 00 buck, or a 40-round mag from an AK. Then I can make a pile of the remains, douse it in gasoline, and light it on fire. The winning bidder would get pics if they so choose. I could even ship you the charred remains if you like. Hey man, I just hate it. Let me know. Whatever trips your trigger."
好的。“我收到了一些邮件。是的，我愿意放火烧掉它，用子弹把它打满洞，等等，并给你寄一张图片/视频。如果出价足够高以支付我的成本，我愿意用以下方式把它打满洞——12号口径弹丸、00鹿弹，或者一个AK的40发弹夹。然后我可以把残骸堆成一堆，浇上汽油，点火烧了。如果中标者愿意，他们会得到照片。如果你愿意，我甚至可以把烧焦的残骸寄给你。伙计，我就是恨它。让我知道。随你的便。”
And then the next day, apparently in response to other emails, you add the following.
然后第二天，显然是回复其他邮件，你添加了以下内容。
"Yes, I can drive over it with something. I can drive over it with a Massey Ferguson 620-cubic-inch diesel-powered tractor." At this time I only had one bid. It was for a penny. So I wrote, "again, for Chrissakes, the next bid's $0.02. I'm willing to do all this crap for a penny, so the video's got to be worth $5. Bid and tell me what you want."
“是的，我可以开车从它上面碾过去。我可以开一辆马赛福格森620立方英寸柴油动力的拖拉机碾过去。”当时我只有一个出价。只有一分钱。所以我写道，“再说一次，看在上帝的份上，下一个出价是0.02美元。我愿意为了一分钱做所有这些烂事，所以视频必须值5美元。出价并告诉我你想要什么。”
And then the next day, apparently, people are writing you about the bottle. So you had to make this addendum.
然后第二天，显然，人们在给你写关于瓶子的事。所以你不得不加了这个附录。
"For those who are interested, the bottle does carry a $0.10 Michigan deposit, and it's pre-printed for the other standard deposits for other states, which is $0.05. So yeah, it's like a huge bonus, worth hundreds of times what the table is worth."
“对于那些感兴趣的人，瓶子确实包含0.10美元的密歇根州押金，并且预印有其他州的标准押金，即0.05美元。所以是的，这就像一个巨大的奖励，价值是台子价值的数百倍。”
So how many people looked at this site?
有多少人看了这个网站？
At the time the auction ended, I had about 40,000 views. And it kept going around. I noticed it was up on some message boards on the internet. As of this morning, I had, I think, 202,000 views.
拍卖结束时，我有大约40000次点击。它一直在流传。我注意到它出现在互联网上的一些留言板上。截至今天早上，我想我有202000次点击。
So you have fans.
所以你有粉丝了。
Yeah, I've got quite a bit of fan mail. I haven't got any hate mail so far, so that's good. But I've had four or five marriage proposals. I hope they're not serious, but--
是的，我收到了不少粉丝邮件。到目前为止我还没收到过仇恨邮件，所以那很好。但我收到了四五个求婚。我希望他们不是认真的，但是——
Wait. Are you-- what did they say in the marriage proposals?
等等。你是——他们在求婚里说了什么？
It's just kind of really odd. They just said, well, you sound funny, and wow, I want to marry you, and I want to meet you, and so on. But I'm married, and happily married, and I have a son. So I guess I wasn't real interested in those. I'm not so sure I'd be interested otherwise anyway.
这简直太奇怪了。他们只是说，嗯，你听起来很有趣，哇，我想嫁给你，我想见你，等等。但我结婚了，婚姻很幸福，还有一个儿子。所以我猜我对那些不感兴趣。即使不是这样，我也不确定我是否会感兴趣。
So who bought the thing.
所以是谁买了那东西。
Well, a guy bought it. And I didn't hear anything from him for a couple of days. So I emailed him, and he just responded that he didn't really want the table. He kind of got caught up in bidding on it. So he just paid me for the table, and that was the end of that.
嗯，是一个人买的。我在接下来几天没收到他的消息。所以我给他发了邮件，他只是回复说他并不真正想要那个台子。他只是在出价时被带进去了。所以他只是付了钱给我，这就是结束了。
Wait, wait, wait. He didn't want it? He just got caught up in the excitement?
等等，等等，等等。他不想要它？他只是被兴奋冲昏了头？
Well, there are a lot of other fictitious or false auctions on eBay. A lot of people will then bid up these things, and nobody's actually serious about completing the transaction, but it's just  kind of understood that the transaction's not going to be completed. It's just for entertainment value.
嗯，易趣上有很多虚构或虚假的拍卖。很多人会抬高这些东西的价格，其实没有人真正认真地完成交易，但大家都心照不宣地知道交易不会完成。这只是为了娱乐价值。
So he assumed that this was that. And I told him I wasn't really concerned about getting the money. But he wanted to pay me for it anyway, because he did win, and he wanted to make sure he got his positive feedback out of the deal.
所以他假设这也是那样。我告诉他我不关心能不能拿到钱。但他还是想付钱，因为他确实赢了，他想确保他能从交易中获得积极的反馈。
He didn't want you ruining his reputation.
他不想让你毁了他的名声。
I guess. He had a pretty good reputation, just like mine. So feedback's everything on eBay.
我猜是吧。他有很好的声誉，就像我的一样。所以易趣上的反馈就是一切。
Wow. I can't believe you actually made money.
哇。我简直不敢相信你真的赚到了钱。
Well, the interesting thing is somebody also Paypaled me $11 to buy myself a six pack of beer because they got so much entertainment out of reading the auction. So I've actually made more money than what I sold it for.
嗯，有趣的是，有人还通过PayPal给了我11美元，让我自己买一箱啤酒，因为阅读拍卖过程让他们得到了太多的娱乐。所以我实际上赚的钱比卖掉它还要多。
Dave lives in Ann Arbor. He did finish the crib, barely. The price he got for his routing table, $26.22.
Dave住在安娜堡。他确实勉强完成了婴儿床。他卖掉路由器台的价格是26.22美元。
[MUSIC - "PIECE OF CRAP" BY NEIL YOUNG]
[音乐 - 尼尔·杨的《垃圾》]
Act Four, The Rocks at Rock Bottom. Well, this is the story of a man who hit rock bottom when he was actually surrounded by a whole lot of rocks, so it's kind of a double rock bottom situation, if you know what I mean. He was living in a small village in Spain at the time, in this kind of formally volcanic area where the mountains meet the sea. And so on the coast right there, instead of sand, the beaches are made up of slate and of stones. Hillary Frank tells the story.
第四幕，《谷底的石头》。嗯，这是一个人在他真正被一大堆石头包围时跌入谷底的故事，所以如果你明白我的意思，这是一个双重谷底的情况。他当时住在一个西班牙的小村庄里，在一个山脉与大海交汇的火山区。所以在那里的海岸上，沙滩不是沙子，而是由板岩和石头组成的。Hillary Frank讲述了这个故事。
Jerry and his wife had split up and he moved to this little village, leaving everything behind, his young son, his home. He was about as low as he'd ever been.
Jerry和他的妻子分开了，他搬到了这个小村庄，抛下了一切，他的小儿子，他的家。他当时跌到了人生最低点。
Thoughts were running around in my head and wouldn't stop. It was like a broken record. And when I lay down at night and tried to sleep, sometimes the most absolutely ridiculous little thing would be running around in my head and I couldn't divert my attention away from it. And I found that walking on the beach, hunched over a little bit, looking for flat rocks, picking up a handful, throwing them in the ocean, and the fact of throwing very hard as well, this relaxed me a great deal.
各种念头在我脑海里奔跑，挥之不去。就像一张坏掉的唱片。当我在晚上躺下试图睡觉时，有时一些绝对荒谬的小事会在我脑海里盘旋，我无法将注意力转移开。我发现走在海滩上，稍微弓着背，寻找平坦的石头，抓一把，把它们扔进海里，加上用力投掷这个动作，这让我非常放松。
Jerry started skipping rocks at the beach five or six times a day for at least a half an hour at a time. The bay at this beach was shaped like a U. Jerry worked on one side of the U and lived on the other. He had to walk along the shore to get home, and on his way, he'd stop to skip stones. Over time, he began walking less and skipping more.
Jerry开始每天在海滩上打水漂五到六次，每次至少半个小时。这个海滩的海湾形状像个U。Jerry在U的一边工作，住在另一边。他必须沿着岸边走回家，在路上，他会停下来打水漂。随着时间的推移，他开始走得少了，打水漂的时间多了。
And one night-- it was during the tourist season, which means that this little bitty village fills up with tourists from all over the world. And right at sundown, it was just gorgeous weather and the bay itself was like glass. And I stopped at the base of the U, which is downtown, so to speak, where the main plaza is. And I was in my own little private world of walking and skipping and the stones just were flying. I mean, it was an extraordinary night. I had no peripheral vision at all. No sound occurred to me.
有一天晚上——那是在旅游旺季，这意味着这个小小的村庄挤满了来自世界各地的游客。就在日落时分，天气非常好，海湾本身就像镜子一样。我在U的底部停了下来，也就是所谓的市中心，主广场所在的地方。我处在自己行走和打水漂的私人世界里，石头飞快地飞着。我的意思是，那是一个非凡的夜晚。我完全没有余光。没有任何声音进入我的意识。
And all of a sudden, the stones were flying out to where the boats were moored. In fact, I'm talking 120 meters, a long way out there, and it actually hit a couple hulls and all that. And it just surprised the heck out of me. And at one particular point, a stone just flew and bounced and bounced and bounced and bounced and kept bouncing and kept bouncing and kept bouncing and I'm standing there agape.
突然之间，石头飞向了船只停泊的地方。事实上，我说的是120米，那是很远的地方，它实际上击中了几个船体等等。这让我大吃一惊。在某一个点上，一块石头飞了出去，反弹、反弹、反弹、反弹、反弹、反弹、反弹，我站在那里目瞪口呆。
And all of a sudden, when it quit and just sank, there was just this spontaneous burst of cheers and applause, which absolutely startled me. And it was like somebody slapped me on the shoulder in a dark room or something. I turned around and there must have been 2 or 3 or 400 people about 60, 80 feet behind me in a great big crescent.
突然之间，当它停止并沉没时，爆发出一阵自发的欢呼和掌声，这让我绝对吃了一惊。就像有人在黑屋子里拍了我的肩膀一样。我转过身，发现身后大概60、80英尺远的地方，聚着两三百人，围成一个大半圆。
And you didn't notice them gathering.
你没有注意到他们在聚集吗？
No. No No, not at all. I didn't have a clue.
不。不，不，完全没有。我一点头绪都没有。
Did you turn around and take a bow or something?
你转过身鞠躬了吗？
No. No! I was embarrassed. No, I just slinked off down the beach and got out of the way. It was like, whoa. Because it was like a very private moment that all of sudden you realize that hi, we're Candid Camera. So I sort of stumbled down the beach to-- there was a cafe outside. And I sat down at one of the tables and ordered a Coke or whatever and realized that I was shaking so bad that I couldn't hold my drink still. Well then I couldn't go anywhere in the village after that because every night I walked and every night I skipped. But I couldn't find a place where I could skip that nobody could see it.
没有。不！我很尴尬。不，我只是溜下海滩避开了。那就像，哇。因为这本来是一个非常私人的时刻，突然你意识到，嘿，这是《隐藏的摄像机》。所以我跌跌撞撞地沿着海滩走到外面的一家咖啡馆。我坐在其中一张桌子旁，点了一杯可乐什么的，意识到我颤抖得太厉害，以至于拿不住饮料。嗯，从那以后我没法在村子里去任何地方了，因为每天晚上我都走，每天晚上我都打水漂。但我找不到一个我可以打水漂而没人看见的地方。
Why was it important to you to try and find a private place?
为什么试图找到一个私人空间对你很重要？
Well because-- I don't know. I guess I'm very shy. And I'm-- that's a good question. I suppose that coming out of a depression and sort of a funk in one's life is sort of a private thing. I mean we all tend to sort of brush that off, don't we, and put on a smiley face with everyone. And it was just at this point in my life things weren't OK. They weren't going well.
嗯，因为——我不知道。我想我很害羞。而我——这是个好问题。我想，从抑郁和生活中某种忧郁中走出来是一种私人的事情。我的意思是，我们都倾向于把它刷掉，不是吗，并对每个人都露出笑脸。就在我生命中的这一点上，事情并不顺利。它们进行得并不好。
And what was going well, I enjoyed to do, and I enjoyed to do it privately. And that was throw rocks at the water. And I didn't want to share my pain in other words. And so then I had to make some conscious decisions about was I going to quit skipping because this was not what I had mind. Or do I go theatrical with it? In other words, [INAUDIBLE]?
对于那些进行得好的事情，我乐于去做，而且我乐于私下里去做。那就是向水里扔石头。换句话说，我不想分享我的痛苦。所以当时我必须做出一些理性的决定：我是不是该因为这和我所想的不一样而放弃打水漂？还是我该去搞点表演？换句话说，[听不清]？
What happened was eventually I would be skipping and children, little German and French kids and Spanish kids, they would come up to me in an absolutely orchestrated order almost stand in line and one by one giving the other one time and room, they would come to me. And they would bring me a stone and ask me to skip it. Or they would bring me a stone and ask if they could skip it and show them how to hold it or whatever. And that went on for a while.
后来发生的事情是，我会打水漂，孩子们，那些德国、法国和西班牙小孩，他们会以一种几乎被精心编排的顺序过来，排着队，一个接一个地给对方留出时间和空间，他们会来到我身边。他们会给我一块石头，让我打水漂。或者他们会给我一块石头，问他们能不能打水漂，让我教他们怎么拿石头等等。这种情况持续了一段时间。
And then pretty soon the older people started getting in line as well. This became a nightly ritual. And I was now being introduced everywhere in the village as here's the stone skipper.
不久之后，年长的人也开始排队了。这成了每天晚上的仪式。我现在在村子里到处都被介绍为：“这是打水漂的人。”
Over time Jerry learned to enjoy skipping rocks in front of an audience. And a few years later when he moved back to Texas, where he's from, he learned that there was actually a Guinness world record for rock skipping, 29 skips. Jerry knew he could beat that record. And eventually he did with 38 skips. Or at least that's all the camera could catch before the rock skipped out of the frame.
随着时间的推移，Jerry学会了在观众面前享受打水漂的乐趣。几年后，当他搬回德克萨斯州老家时，他了解到吉尼斯世界纪录打水漂纪录是29次。Jerry知道他能打破那个纪录。最终他做到了，跳了38次。或者至少那是摄像机在石头跳出画面前所能捕捉到的全部次数。
Jerry says that back on the night he became the village stone skipper at the beach in Spain, he probably got well over 50 which seems unimaginable. For most people, even getting three skips is tough. Jerry says it's really all about physics. That you need to learn to rotate the stone and get it as parallel to the water as possible, while also throwing it down.
Jerry说，在他成为村里的打水漂达人的那个晚上，在西班牙的海滩上，他可能跳了超过50次，这似乎是不可想象的。对大多数人来说，即使打水漂三次也很难。Jerry说这完全是物理学。你需要学习旋转石头，并使其尽可能与水面平行，同时向下扔。
It's just like a basketball or tennis ball or something. If you got in a gymnasium and I got one end and you got at the other, and you said throw me the ball, I'd just throw it to you. That's one thing. Now if you said make it bounce 30 times before it gets to me, I'm going to throw it toward you, but I'm also going to have to throw it down at the floor of the gym pretty hard for it bounce that many times before it gets down there.
就像篮球或网球什么的。如果你在体育馆，我在这一头，你在那一头，你说把球扔给我，我就扔给你。这是一回事。现在如果你说让它在我接到前弹30次，我会把它扔向你，但我也不得不把它用力扔向体育馆的地板，这样它在到达你那里之前才能弹那么多次。
Jerry also says the size of the rock is important. It needs to be almost as big as the palm of your hand and uniformly thick.
Jerry还说石头的大小很重要。它需要几乎像你的手掌那么大，而且厚度均匀。
If somebody said skip an Oreo cookie for 20 times, I couldn't do it because there's not much mass to an Oreo cookie. And I've tried that.
如果有人说把一块奥利奥饼干打水漂20次，我做不到，因为奥利奥饼干没有多少质量。我试过那个。
You've tried skipping an Oreo cookie?
你试过打水漂奥利奥饼干？
Well actually, I did a program. They came out and wanted to film me skipping a whole basket full of different things from bagels to cans of tuna. And by the way, bagels are best skipper in that food group. And if it's frozen, I can probably skip it pretty well.
嗯，实际上，我做了一个节目。他们过来想拍我打水漂一整篮不同的东西，从百吉饼到金枪鱼罐头。顺便说一句，百吉饼是该食品类中最好的水漂材料。如果是冷冻的，我可以打得很好。
So you need to have a decent sized stone and be able to throw it down. But probably the most important element in getting a stone to skip far is being able to throw it hard, like you would if you were angry. And anger, after all, is what made Jerry so good at this sport to begin with.
所以你需要有一个大小适中的石头并能够用力扔下去。但让石头跳得远最重要的因素，可能是有能力用力扔，就像你愤怒时那样。毕竟，愤怒正是Jerry起初在这个运动中变得如此出色的原因。
When I find myself headed down a road of depression or boredom or whatever else, I look for a pond and some flat rocks. It was something that worked for me once and it'll work for me again.
当我发现自己走向抑郁、无聊或任何其他道路时，我会寻找一个池塘和一些平坦的石头。这是曾经对我有效的事情，它会再次有效。
It kind of seems like that perfect combination of a kind of aggression and meditation.
这看起来像是那种攻击性和冥想的完美结合。
Well, I'll tell you something, Hillary. In fact I had four stone skipping events in four consecutive years at one point there. And during the course of doing these events, I met a wide spectrum of people. One in particular was a guy that came up to me and said-- he was from Chicago in fact, by the way-- and he worked with at-risk delinquent children, and had told me this story of how these kids, one of their favorite pastimes was chucking rocks through factory windows from the alleys and all in Chicago. And so instead of round rocks in an alley, he found them flat rocks in a pond, and said it was absolutely phenomenal the effect that skipping stones had on these children.
嗯，我告诉你一件事，Hillary。事实上，有一次我在连续四年里举行了四次打水漂活动。在举行这些活动的过程中，我遇到了各种各样的人。其中一个特别的人走过来对我说——顺便说一句，他是来自芝加哥的——他与高危违纪儿童一起工作，并告诉我这个故事，说这些孩子最喜欢的消遣之一就是从巷子里把石头扔进工厂的窗户。所以，他没有给他们巷子里的圆形石头，而是给他们找了池塘里的平坦石头，他说打水漂对这些孩子的影响简直是太惊人了。
It does seem ideal. For all those times you want to punch a wall or a person, just to take a breath, walk to a place where the water lies still, and there's an abundance of flat, smooth rocks.
这看起来确实很理想。在你想要拳击墙壁或人，只想喘口气，走到水面静止的地方，并且有大量平坦、光滑的石头的时候，这是一种极好的方式。
Hillary Frank.
Hillary Frank。
Well, our program was produced today by Sarah Koenig and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Wendy Dorr, Jane Feltes, and Lisa Pollak, our senior producer, Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website, production help from Todd Bachmann and Kelsey Dilts.
嗯，我们的节目今天由Sarah Koenig和我本人制作，Alex Blumberg、Diane Cook、Wendy Dorr、Jane Feltes和Lisa Pollak参与制作，我们的高级制作人是Julie Snyder。Elizabeth Meister运营我们的网站，Todd Bachmann和Kelsey Dilts提供制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our programs for free or buy CDs of them, or you know you can download audio of our program at audible.com/thisamericanlife, where they have public radio programs, best-selling books, even The New York Times , all at audible.com. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站www.thisamericanlife.org，您可以免费收听我们的节目或购买CD，或者您知道可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载我们节目的音频，那里有公共广播节目、畅销书，甚至《纽约时报》，都在audible.com。 《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. And he has a secret.
WBEZ管理监督Torey Malatia。他有个秘密。
Sh. You can call me The Terminator. You're the only one that knows this.
嘘。你可以叫我“终结者”。你是唯一知道这件事的人。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。